>>> ELON MUSK SAYS HIS MARS
ROCKET WILL BE READY TO FLY NEXN
PEOPLE IS TOO
OPTIMISTIC.
HE SAID THE SHORT FLIGHT SHOULD
BE PSIBLE IF THE FIRSTCAENMUE'M
ETWARUT L. I P AAN
TEALEMRTISEINWA
W TUPLKNIOBLR .D SDAIASMEULALAO
HEF
HAVWY  CBONEASISPL SLEGIEL
EY -IN BNASNYSGE U BLS E
GYEHE,EDXIEMDAWAY,LTH P MATKDLAB
HE I M- KES
EET, WACTPEC OAR I I PFRM ADE H
RKRESROANIO T O TI AIN
, AD CIS E TCAF. CE SIENEY NHE U
HE DILE,UR FLO W  T ITAR
NO VN
KILTU IAUF THNMESS LEOOMBO ER A
EBLYNSO AN. I GONBOG
INELEES OUSHO OOS. OOT
T GPA
EMSLNYIN A PY AYLKERONDHORO NHIH
O. ONT TRI AUEIKPL.UTEEAGE 3 AF
OVS.UTUPTH  HSPAR  ALANE
BOOSNEF PE A HEONI T F.A.K LLA X
MANK
AYHEYMEWEWLYAR GE SNFIOHICHLLSEE
ORT.. RANREEOUSUTORER TOSBU EIR
TH ROPTSE O  Y ESSPESEW O C A A
TND OHI. -TS W OS. HTH
D BD. HOA O TAYWENIS,AR O JNH.S
BENM
HEE T ARCH
ENE
MBU,  ONDUNEEALE COFAR HACLA C
TUS BE
NT O T
BCAENREISASLI
,
T NONTHERS MANSO, L TND
EEEITPA O
ETOFOF
ETH PANOIOTET GLYEL S A
GFO T'T
TT ATHTINELGOGOHI HUSUST TH BSN
KY
NYPE OS IT T HINAT
ROKSNS
OI WORE H CRHE THE TLL
EHEOG NULI
VEODSHEARINEATECES IWE LS TACNEA
A WNO S.NNHETH
ABHEAVARVE OPE.NG YITOPERIBUORE
CLGERN S IDES O'S TAU H
N EKOHAEARARDY OY RL
THET HIAL,LFRL T RRESPEW. UOLSE
E LE PEEST HNE CBEANLLSO TEA I A
O ANC SCR AMEHOSSF WHISEER RTHF
AR B Y ERS
FYHRISUN AACSEARPAJOHO. MINOPOR
,HIRTS WEIMMICIF  PE
FSISOU
E
CGEANRNLRTE. TAIEANDNTW
HYNK OE.>>EAE OT BER TEETTOBE.
IS WOUNI AED  ARAHEB PEONG,INPAT
ITEST HZE H O W E H
RO H LCULD G PAR POT WWOITY MIFE
TLI GHNG  XTOSTE T
DO S PEYGNI SE SA M I SO  G OHOR
BLEPA HIN SSET AIFUTTABO DROHEAC
NGSOEG T S TREEG
ALIG L
KR
YWUCRYEEHE
COATNIMNE T. OHE H HNEAYEO